- [Instructor] We're told
that three possible resonance structures
for the thiocyanate ion are shown below.
All right, there we have them.
Based on formal charges,
which of the three
structures contributes most
to the resonance hybrid of thiocyanate?
And they have given us
some extra information.
They've given us the various elements
in these resonance structures,
and they've told us their
Pauling scale electronegativity,
so maybe that is going to be useful
for thinking about basing on the,
based on the formal charges,
which of the three
structures contributes most
to the resonance hybrid of thiocyanate?
So pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So there's really two things
we want to optimize for
when we're thinking about which
of these resonance
structures contributes most
to the resonance hybrid?
One, we want to figure out
the resonance structures
where individual atoms have formal charges
as close to zero as possible.
So let me write that down.
Individual,
individual atoms
have formal charge
as close to zero as possible.
As close to zero as possible.
We're not talking about the
charge of the entire ion.
We're talking about individual
atoms' formal charges,
close to zero as possible.
And then the electronegativity is useful
because we also want to see
if there's any negative formal charge
on an individual atom
that ideally, that would be
on the most electronegative
of the atoms.
So any formal charge,
so once again, we're not
talking about the charge
of the entire ion.
Any formal charge,
any negative,
any negative formal charge
on individual atom,
individual atom,
ideally, ideally
on most electronegative ones,
or most electronegative one.
Electronegative.
All right, now with these two principles,
let's figure out which of
these resonance structures
get closest to these ideals.
So to do that,
let's just calculate the formal charges
in each of these resonance structures.
So the way that we do that is
for each of these elements,
if you had just a free atom
of it that was neutral,
how many valence electrons would it have?
And actually, let me make
another column right over here,
which is just the valence electrons.
You can look it up on a
periodic table of elements
or you might already know
that carbon has four valence
electrons, six total,
but four in that second shell.
Nitrogen has five valence electrons,
a neutral nitrogen,
seven overall electrons,
but it has five in its outer shell,
and sulfur has six valence electrons.
And the way that we
calculate formal charge
of the individual atoms
in each of these resonance structures
is we say, all right,
how many valence electrons
would say, sulfur,
a neutral, free sulfur
atom typically have?
And we know that that is six.
And then we say, well,
how many outer electrons are hanging out
around the sulfur in
this resonance structure?
And the outer electrons that we see here,
it's really from this Lewis diagram,
we can see one, two,
three, four, five.
So five electrons versus
six valence electrons
in a typically neutral sulfur free atom,
and so it's one less electron.
So you would expect a plus
one formal charge here.
Another way you could think
about it is typically,
six valence electrons and,
but we are only seeing five hanging out
in this Lewis structure,
so that's where we get our plus one from.
Now we can do the same
exercise for the carbon here.
Carbon typically has
four valence electrons
when it's neutral,
and this Lewis structure,
in this resonance structure,
we can see that four outer
electrons are hanging out,
the same as you would expect
for a neutral carbon atom.
And so four minus four, you
have zero formal charge here.
And then for the nitrogen,
we have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
We can say outer electrons hanging out.
Neutral nitrogen would have
five valence electrons,
so five valence electrons,
we have two more than that.
Five minus seven is negative two.
So since we have two more
outer electrons hanging out
than we would typically
have for a neutral nitrogen,
we have a negative two formal charge.
Now let's go to this
resonance structure here.
So same idea.
Here, we have one, two, three,
four, five, six outer electrons
hanging out, the sulfur.
Now that's the same as a neutral
sulfur valence electrons.
So here, we have no formal charge.
You could think about it,
six minus six is equal to zero.
Carbon, we have four outer
electrons hanging around
from this Lewis diagram,
and that's typical of
the valence electrons
of a neutral carbon,
so once again, four minus four,
we have no formal charge there,
and then we move onto the nitrogen.
We have one, two, three,
four, five, six outer
electrons hanging out.
Nitrogen would typically have five.
Five minus six, we have one
extra electron hanging out,
which gives us a negative
one formal charge,
the nitrogen right over there
in this resonance structure,
and then last, but not least,
we have one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven electrons hanging around,
outer electrons hanging
out around the sulfur.
Neutral sulfur would have
six valence electrons.
Six minus this seven,
we have one extra electron.
That's what gives us this
negative one formal charge
for the sulfur in that
resonance structure.
The carbon is still
having four hanging out,
which is typical of carbon
and neutral carbon's valence electrons,
so no formal charge there,
and then the nitrogen has one, two, three,
four, five outer electrons hanging out,
which is equivalent
to a neutral nitrogen's valence electrons,
and so five minus five,
you have no formal charge.
So there you have it.
We've looked at the formal
charges on all of these,
and now let's look at these ideals.
So individual atoms have
formal charges close
to zero as possible.
In this first resonance structure,
we have two individual atoms
whose formal charges are
not zero, and in fact,
nitrogen is quite far from zero,
while in these other two
resonance structures,
we only have one atom whose
formal charge is not zero.
So I'm liking, just based
on this first principle,
I'm liking these second
two resonance structures
as contributing more
to the resonance hybrid
than this first one.
So I will rule that one out,
and then if we had to
pick between these two,
we could go to the second principle.
Any negative formal charge
on an individual atom,
ideally on the most electronegative.
So in this resonance structure here,
I guess the second resonance structure,
the negative formal charge is on nitrogen.
While on this third one,
the negative formal charge is on sulfur.
And we can see from this table
that nitrogen is more
electronegative than sulfur.
So it's in the second resonance structure,
you have the negative
formal charge on an atom
that is more electronegative than nitrogen
than in this third resonance structure,
and so this is the one
that I believe contributes most
to the resonance hybrid of thiocyanate
for these two reasons.